i am so proud
to stand here today
as prime minister
of four nations in one united kingdom
i was always clear about why we called
that referendum
duck the fight and our union could have
been taken apart
bit by bit
take it on
and we have the chance to settle the
question
this party has always confronted the big
issues for the sake of our country
and now
england scotland wales northern ireland
we are one people in one union and
everyone here can be proud of that the
threat is islamist extremist terrorism
and it has found a new hellish crucible
with isil in iraq and syria
these people
they are evil pure and simple
they kill children rape women threaten
non-believers with genocide behead
journalists and aid workers
now some people seem to think we can opt
out of this
we can't
as i speak british servicemen and women
are flying in the skies over iraq
they saw action
yesterday and there will be troops on
the front line
but they will be iraqis kurds and
syrians fighting for the safe and
democratic future that they deserve
we are acting in partnership with a
range of countries including those from
the region
because let us be clear
there is no walk on by option
unless we deal with isil
they will deal with us bringing terror
and murder to our streets now when he
was a teenager
he didn't only address the tory party
conference
he read hansard in bed
and he had a record collection that
apparently consisted of one album by
dire straits
and dozens of speeches by winston
churchill
his dad said
he was just a normal happy boy
well all i can say is this that boy
became an amazing parliamentarian a
brilliant foreign secretary our greatest
living yorkshireman and someone to whom
i owe an enormous debt of gratitude
william hey
you work hard we will cut your taxes
but only if we keep cutting the deficit
so we can afford to do that
for those wanting to buy a home
yes we will help you get on that housing
ladder
but only if we take on the vested
interests and build more homes however
hard that may be
we will make sure your children get a
great education the best education
but only if we keep on taking on
everybody
who gets in the way of high standards
and for those retiring
we will make sure you get a decent
pension and real rewards for your life
in work
but only if we as a country
except we all have to work a bit longer
and save a bit more with the next
conservative government we will always
have the most competitive corporate
taxes in the g20 lower than germany
lower than japan lower than the united
states that is our commitment
but george
george said something really important
in that absolutely brilliant speech on
monday
a message to those global companies
we have cut your taxes now you must pay
what you owe
we won't just aim to lower youth
unemployment
we aim to abolish it
and we have made clear decisions
we will reduce the benefits cap and we
will say to those 21 and under
no longer will you have the option of
leaving school and going straight into a
life on benefits
you must earn
or learn
and we will help by funding 3 million
apprenticeships let us say to our young
people a life on welfare that is no life
at all instead here is some hope here is
a chance to get on and make something of
your lives that is our message to young
people in britain today when companies
employ staff on zero hours conflict
contracts and then stop them from
getting work elsewhere
that is not a free market
that is a fixed market
in a britain that everyone is proud to
call home people are employed they are
not used so those exclusive zero-hours
contracts that left people unable to
build decent lives for themselves we
will scrap them criminal gangs
trafficking people halfway around the
world and making them work in the most
disgusting conditions
i've been to see these
houses on our terraced streets
built for families of four but cramming
in 15 people like animals
and to those crime lords who think they
can get away with it i say no not in
this country not with this party our
modern slavery bill will mean we are
coming after you and we are going to put
a stop to it once and for all
today right here today
the minimum wage reaches six pounds
fifty an hour and before long we'll
reach our next goal of seven pounds an
hour
and i can tell you now that a future
conservative government will raise the
tax-free personal allowance from ten
thousand five hundred pounds to twelve
thousand five hundred pounds with a
conservative government
we will raise the threshold at which
people pay the forty p rate
it is currently forty one thousand nine
hundred pounds
in the next parliament we will raise it
to 50 000 pounds
look ed
people forget their car keys my children
sometimes forget their homework
i once even forgot that i left nancy
down the pub
um
samantha i'm sorry it won't happen again
but let me say this you cannot be prime
minister of this country and forget the
most important issue that we face
here is our renewed commitment
to first-time buyers
if you're prepared to work and save we
will help you get a place of your own
at this conference we've announced a
landmark new policy it's called starter
homes
we're going to build a hundred thousand
new homes and they will be at least 20
percent cheaper than normal
but here's the crucial part
buy to let landlords won't be able to
snap them up
wealthy foreigners won't be able to buy
them just first-time buyers under the
age of 40 homes built for you made for
you our party the conservative party the
party of home ownership once again i've
got a bit of news for you
it's something we've never really said
before
we in this party
we are a trade union too
and i tell you who we represent this
party is the union for hard-working
parents for the father who reads his
children's stories at night because he
wants them to learn the mother who works
all the hours god sends to give her
children the best start this party is
the trade union for children from the
poorest estates and the most chaotic
homes this party is the union for the
young woman who wants an apprenticeship
for the teenagers who want to make
something of their lives this is who we
resent these are the people that we are
fighting for and that is why on
education we will not let labour drag us
back to square one we're going to finish
what we have begun this is personal i'm
someone who has relied on the nhs and
whose family knows more than most just
how important it is who knows what it's
like when you go to hospital night after
night with a sick child in your arms
knowing that when you get there there
were people who will love that
child and care for that child just as
like it was their own and how dare they
suggest i would ever put that at risk
for other people's children how dare
they frighten those who rely on a
national health service
the next conservative government will
protect the nhs budget and continue to
invest more because we know this truth
something labor will never understand
and we will never forget
you can only have a strong nhs if you
have a strong economy we know the bigger
issue today is migration from within the
eu
immediate access to our welfare system
paying benefits to families back at home
employment agencies signing up people
from overseas not recruiting here
numbers that have increased faster than
we in this country wanted and at a level
that was too much for our communities
and for our labor markets
all of this has to change
and it will be at the very heart of my
renegotiation strategy for europe
britain
i know you want this sorted so i will go
to brussels i will not take no for an
answer and when it comes to free
movement
i will get what britain needs
they know i say what i mean and i mean
what i say
so we're going to go in as a country
we're going to get our powers back we're
going to fight for our national interest
and yes we'll put it to a referendum in
or out it will be your choice and let
the message go out from this hall it is
only with the conservatives that you
will get that choice with a conservative
government after the next election this
country will have a new british bill of
rights to be passed in our parliament
rooted in our values and as for labour's
human rights act we will scrap it once
and for all this is a straight fight
it doesn't matter whether parliament is
hung drawn or courted there is only one
real choice
the conservatives or labor
me in downing street
or ed miliband in downing street
if you vote ukip
that is really a vote for labor
and here's a thought
here is a thought for you
on the 7th of may
you could go to bed with nigel farage
and wake up with ed miliband
i
i don't know about you but not one bit
of that works for me
are at the moment
where all the hard work is finally
paying off
and the light is coming up after some
long dark days
go back now and we'll lose all we've
done
falling back into the shadows when we
should be striding into the sun
that's the question
next may
do you want to go back to square one
or finish what we have begun
this is a great country and we can be
greater still because history is not
written for us but by us in the
decisions that we make today
and that starts
next may
so britain
what's it going to be
i say let's not go back to square one
let us finish what we have begun let us
build a britain we are proud to call
home for you for your family for
everyone